you can buy pens at pen island net buoy
and the most awesome guitar ever it's
episode 11 of IMG hey buds sup player
here's Shaquille O'Neal and here he is
last weekend for Halloween as shaquita
ndse saying Beyonce but if you're still
not terrified take a look at this
picture it's scary enough on its own but
there's something else twisted about it
the photo was taken with a pinhole
camera built out of an actual human
skull poodles are super cool especially
if you shave them and dye them to look
like roosters offensive linemen or bison
I am NOT an artist org is a great source
of fun animated gifs lots of them in
fact all on one page
remember cassette tapes well here are
some melted down squished and gutted to
resemble skulls and bones and now the
time has come I hope you guys are ready
you're gonna have to trust me on this
one put your hand right here with your
palm facing the screen okay is it there
alright good now sit back and enjoy
animals giving you high fives
and if that was too cute for you here's
damage comms collection of things that
look like let's move on to yarn beards
last week I showed you how to protect
information
well now someone else is doing the
opposite these mysterious drives are
located in eight different places across
New York City and people can plug in and
share and copy and delete whatever they
want there is an easier way to share
funny pictures of course facebook.com
slash vsauce gaming like us on Facebook
and share and view pictures from other V
saucers just like yourself be sure to
subscribe to our channel on YouTube and
use these pictures to watch other
episodes of IMG collect them all and
thanks for watching
you